a big thing about art is getting to
share that joy of what you do with other
people I took this art studio class at
MIT and on the first day this teacher
asked the students why were we here and
a lot of them had really similar answers
it was basically I used to do art in
high school and I want to continue it
here in that MIT but I didn't really
have the chance so I wanted to make this
project where other MIT students could
do that thing being where they could
really do art and have other people
appreciate it and get involved in like
find happiness out of that
[Music]
the borderline is a project where we're
really trying to get MIT community
involved with art in a kind of informal
way those open MIT students to just
paint a mural that they want and have it
in a public space so other people could
really enjoy it and interact with it
there's only a lot of artists on campus
that contribute a lot to the community
that I guess you just don't really hear
about because they do it on their own
when we were looking for submissions for
this project we got so many from people
that we didn't even know we're doing art
on campus I've never done really
anything visual before but I do have the
background mechanical engineering where
I'm used to building things and trying
to make things look good and work and be
very thorough in all my details and it
was really cool to be able to apply that
in a very different way and I have
before I've done only one mural before
but I look around all the time and see
things as a blank canvas until it's over
an obvious choice for me at least it not
only liven up this place but it really
makes it a destination when you think
about a mural usually think about a
two-dimensional flat piece of work right
so for this project we decided to add an
augmented reality component to it we
made an out worth you take your phone
and you look at the mural with it you'll
see hidden animation start playing
across it so it's no longer a still
piece of artwork it's an animated piece
of work that also exists on its own as a
2d mural if you don't have the app it
was really cool to be part of this
project that started from nothing and
made something very real and something
very tangible and like you can go down
there and see it
this kind of kick started having more
student art that's large on campus and
it would be great if this project itself
could continue if we said maybe use more
space in the tunnel or white wall over
this and use the same space either way I
think it's just really great I hear so
many people talking about how they're so
happy that tunnels have some in them now
all these people come from such
different backgrounds we have freshmen
who are in biology we have seniors who
are mechanical engineers but I think it
just goes to show that there's a lot of
cool things that MIT people can do die
they don't really have a chance to
showcase
besides engineering in their classes and
stuff and so this is like a little
outlet for them to showcase other sides
of themselves
[Music]